a frico camp and welcome to another
daily program or web series and in this
one we're going to be talking about the
3-sum problem which is number 323 posted
on the daily program or subreddit let's
go ahead and break it down on the
whiteboard so the 3-sum problem is
defined like so given an array or lists
of numbers print out all the
combinations of three numbers which when
summed up equate to zero so for example
if I were to try to choose negative 8
negative 7 and 5 as our first
combination when added together do these
sum up to 0 and this will be no because
we actually get negative 10 when we send
this up so then we can try another
combination such as negative 8 5 and 2
and when this is sum together we are
left with a negative 1 so again know
this combination is not sum to 0 and
then the last combination we can
actually try would be negative 7 5 & 2
which when summed up does give us 0 so
in this particular input case where we
had negative 8 negative 7 5 and to the
own combination of three numbers that
sum to 0 would be this combination right
here
so we print this out to the console or
return in some type of array and that
would be your solution for that input so
that basically sums up the 3-sum problem
let's go ahead and break the sound
further to visualize with more
combinations so let's first reduce the
larger problem into something easier to
understand such as a sub-problem where
how do you find all the combinations or
you can pick one number and check it as
some as a 0 well obviously we have to
loop over all the numbers and only have
one variable to keep track of our index
and for each one we just print out the
number and check of equals 0 so I would
be 0 and of course we think of I to get
negative 7 we increment I again to get 5
and then we increment I one more time to
get 2 so that should be obvious right if
you want to check all the combinations
of one number you just have a for loop
and loop over and print out the number
but now let's say you wanted to print
out all the combinations where you pick
two numbers so in this case we have to
first keep track of I and then also keep
track and J it should be equal to I plus
1 so if you were to increment through
this we first print out negative 8
negative 7 the increment I by 1 or sorry
to be an increment J by 1 to print out
negative 8 and 5 increment J again which
allows us to print out the combination
negative 8 and 2 and then when J hits
the end of the array and go ahead and
increment I by 1 and set J equal to I
plus 1 which gives us negative 7 is 5
and then increment J again which gives
us negative 7 in 2 and then lastly we're
going to increment I and set J equal to
I plus 1 which gives us our last
combination of 5 and 2 so hopefully that
makes sense basically we in this case we
have two for loops where we have one
loop that loops over I to the anody
array and then nest and inside that we
have another loop where J is equal to I
plus 1 and they would loop to the end of
the array and that will give us all the
different combinations where we can pick
two numbers so then you can kind of
intuitively thankful if we need to pick
3 numbers for this 3-sum problem we just
need to add another loop right so again
let's work through that so instead of
just having 2 we'd have an I we'd have a
J and we have a K so starting off K
would be J plus 1 and J is equal to I
plus 1 so this will be if it's our first
combination of negative 8 negative 7 and
5 and then we just go ahead and
increment K by 1
which gives us negative 8 negative 7 and
2 and since K is reached the end we
increment J by 1 and then set k equal to
j plus 1 which gives us the combination
negative 8 negative 7 or sorry negative
8 5 and 2 and then lastly since J has
reached the last partner theory that I
can get to we need to increment I by 1
set J is equal to I plus 1 and set K is
equal to J plus 1 which will give us a
very last combination of negative 7 5 &
2 so that's kind of how you work out
printing out all the different
combinations on paper and then it should
be intuitive how you do that in the
computer with 3 4 loops and then down
here you just send them up see if they
equal to 0 and of course the only
solution that equals 0 will be this last
combination here so as you add more
numbers down the road your loops will
just go further and further and they
print out more combinations so let's go
ahead and go to JavaScript and try to
implement this logic so after we're
looking at the whiteboard example of how
to solve this problem it should be
pretty straightforward of how to
implement it right we talked about
learning in three different loops for I
J and K and the hard part is going to be
figuring out how to initialize our where
to initialize the a J and K ad and then
how far they should loop over so
starting off is going to write a
function called three sums and it's
going to take in a parameter of numbers
then in here we're going to go ahead and
declare an array called sets and return
that which is going to be you know all
the different combinations we found
which do match zero and then here we
have to start doing our loop so we can
say for let I is equal to zero
I left some numbers that length minus
two because you can remember we stopped
two away from the ending of the number
list so you can increment that and then
we can declare a J which is equal to I
plus 1 because we need to start one
after the I and then we can say J is
less than
number length minus one because again an
example we stopped one away from the end
because K will always take that last
spot and then lastly if we can say like
K is equal to J plus 1 and then K is
less than the numbers out length and
then increment K and and because K will
go all the way to the unity right so now
that we have our three loops what we can
do here is declare three numbers so I'll
sit constant a is equal to numbers dot
of I I say canta B is equal the numbers
of J and the finally Const of C is equal
to numbers of K so that will give us our
three numbers to make up the combination
and then lastly we can check if a plus B
plus C is equal to zero we go ahead and
push into that sets array those three
numbers so I'll just go ahead and
represent that as a string here of a
string of a B and C and then at the end
we just return our set
so now I should be able to run this and
should give all the combinations which
sum to zero so one thing to point out
here is that what's printed out is going
to contain duplicate combinations and
that is because a set that we put in at
the input has multiple numbers at the
same type so we simple check we can do
to make sure that duplicates do not
happen is we can say add an end for this
check so a B and C adds together equal
zero and sets index of set is equal to
negative one then up here I can say set
is equal to that stream array and I can
push that so one more time we're just
pulling out that string and wait to
variable we're checking if the array
already contains that string or that set
which means index of equal to negative
one which we haven't seen it before and
then finally we just push it into the
set as we did before so now I run this
we hit all the combinations at some of
the zero and we don't get duped
all right so that wraps up the three
somes problem there's other ways to
solve this there's actually a faster way
to do this which if you go to the
subreddit you can read about that but
for the most part I think this is a good
overview of how to write code to solve a
whole like combinations problem all
right if you like this tutorial give us
a thumbs up and be sure to subscribe to
free code camp below alright thanks for
watching